so donald trump has been freaking
out on twitter melting down since
last night highly triggered by the
senate results and trump
again raising this idea of huge
dumps of votes the guy can't behave
normally for five minutes and donald
trump even in advance of last night's
results
which we actually knew relatively
quickly all things considered
tweeting around 10 p.m last night looks
like they are setting up a big
voter dump against the republican
candidates
waiting to see how many votes they need
and of course this never happened donald
trump whatever massive dumps he was
involved in or believed were coming
it just never happened from the
standpoint of the race and in fact
democrats were winning early trump's
scenario is always
republicans are way ahead and then
massive dumps come in
and then democrats win democrats were
winning early and then the race is
tightened as more votes were counted
and then it was just slow slow slow
steady vote counts going one way and the
other and eventually it became clear
that democrats would win by a small
margin in both races because
outstanding votes were overwhelmingly
from very very blue areas areas areas
that went
um three to two for the democratic
challengers even even three to one in
some cases so
no massive dumps no small dumps just an
election that was counted
and and it was all pretty unremarkable
uh from the standpoint of of election
integrity and counting and
it really set trump off and he spent
most of the night tweeting and
retweeting stuff
tweeting at midnight eastern then at 1
am calling on mike pence to steal him
the presidency
saying quote if vice president mike
pence comes through for us
we will win the presidency many states
want to decertify the mistake they made
in certifying incorrect and even
fraudulent numbers
in a process not approved by their state
legislatures which it must be
those are all lies by the way and trump
adds mike can send it back
that won't happen mike pence reportedly
explaining to trump yesterday i can't
overturn the results
and we'll talk a little bit about that
later based on a very good new york
times report but
finishing up with the trump meltdown
then this morning again donald trump
just
out of control first attacking reporter
chuck todd
as sleepy eyes chuck todd
is so happy with the fake voter
tabulation process
that he can't even get the words out
straight sad to watch
and trump's anger knows no limits he
will attack anybody for anything
at any time when he's melting down again
claiming quote
states want to correct their votes which
they now
know were based on irregular
irregularities and
fraud plus corrupt process never
received legislative approval
all mike pence has to do is send him
back to the states
and we win do it mike this
is a time for extreme courage and behind
the scenes there are reports
that trump is reportedly going to
absolutely turn on his own vice
president mike pence
if pence doesn't do something today when
the vote count starts
uh which we will be covering live and
then apparently realizing that the
senate is lost
donald trump sending out an all-caps
tweet this morning
saying the republican party and more
importantly our country
needs the presidency more than ever
before
the power of the veto suggesting
democrats will have the house
democrats will have the senate you need
me there to veto
the things that they will do truly
crumbling before our very eyes the
republican party
collapsing around donald trump and
uh we we essentially have to see what
else he breaks on the way out whoa my
microphone there uh flipping out there
uh we have to see what else he breaks on
the way out as i've said before there's
a reason that many companies will
escort folks out when their position has
been terminated
right away and it's to prevent them from
doing damage on the way out and of
course donald trump having months
during which he can do that damage so
later today we will talk about the
conversation
where mike pence had to explain to trump
i i can't just overturn the results
we will talk about what to expect over
the next few days
let me know your reaction to the
democratic wins in georgia
i'm on twitter at deepakman regardless
of your
workout nutrition and diet goals it is
crucial to have the right amount of
protein in your diet and if you're
supplementing with protein powders you
should be sure you have the powder that
is right for you
and that's where our sponsor gainful
comes in gainful
offers customized protein based on your
body type
diet fitness habits and goals their
formulas are optimized
for you with simple and effective
ingredients no fillers
gluten soy or anything artificial and
gainful also gives you free
unlimited one-on-one access to your own
registered dietitian
which is a great bonus you won't find
anywhere else and my favorite part is
that gainful protein is never repetitive
or
boring because they will rotate the
flavors you choose
like rich chocolate cookies and cream
chocolate peanut butter strawberry cream
cafe mocha i took their quiz and they
gave me protein tailored to
my specific needs everything was quick
and easy i've been loving what they sent
me
you'll get fifteen dollars off your
first month
when you go to gainful.com pacman the
link is underneath this video